there's a hell of a lot of stuff work
that needs doing Prince Harry and Megan
Markel are thinking about the future
a royal source tells ET that the
newlyweds are eager to start a family
and have discussed their desire to have
children quote Harry is tactile and
protective of his new wife he is
completely besotted and nothing would
make him happier if they were starting a
family
in March expert Katie Nichol dished to
ET about Megan and Harry's family
planning my sources are saying that
Prince Harry particularly is very keen
to start a family you know pretty soon
after the royal wedding he's he's made
no secret about wanting children and I
think that moment for him really kicked
in when his brother Prince William of
course settled down with Kate Middleton
they had two children and that has
definitely gotten Prince Harry very
broody the couple also opened up about
starting a family during their first
joint interview together following their
engagement last year I think one thing
one step at a time and if you will start
a family
but for now they're focusing on their
public service we're a fantastic team we
know we land and what we hope to over
time try and have as much impact for the
things that we care about as well they
wanted to hit the ground running after
their marriage to focus on their
charitable interests and Megan is really
looking forward to representing Her
Majesty on her first major Commonwealth
tour to Australia Fiji Tonga and New
Zealand the source adds megan is quote
taking the new job part of her role
seriously having meetings with Palace
staff and learning about the
Commonwealth so she can support Harry in
his new role as Commonwealth Youth
Ambassador
you
[Music]